[Musique]
le petit bois pas si simple au début
[Applaudissements]
mais avec un peu d'entraînement et les
bons profs il faut se lancer et le sens
du rythme se révèle on commence alors un
seul musée
[Applaudissements]
le sens du rythme en fait ça s'acquiert
au fur et à mesure parce que tout et
apprentissage une fois qu'on a compris
le principe que c'est tout le principe à
ce moment là au fur et à mesure on est à
l'aise et on y va
mais il ya une deuxième dimension c'est
le plaisir personnel
on sait à la fois un une technique un
plaisir personnel et puis vous fois
qu'on s'est libéré dont tu te bats tout
ça si votre plaisir aussi
ah oui c'est mon plaisir le plus long
plus le boucher un formidable
l'association ela au de crozant ville a
toute sa place lors d'une journée du
patrimoine ailleurs le public ne s'y
trompe pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que pour le néophyte assez
fait que c'est un petit peu dur mais en
se calquant bien sous le rythme mais on
arrive à achever un petit peu puisque on
a ça dans le sang quand même hein donc
le rite dans son hall 1 allée visiter
juste ionisé et puis la cia surprise
mais ça fait du bien ça fait suer le
bailey's ce sont différents rythmes qui
se joue ce chambre et se danse et pour
les petits l'activité pour l'année
semble toute trouvée
si même petit à petit déjà à la maison
et puis moi aussi donc on continue et
puis le fait de pouvoir profitent avec
les enfants c'est encore mieux parce
qu'on partage un peu
le patrimoine la danse la joie et puis
c'est bien de montrer ça aux enfants
quoi les musiciens des lao sont des
passionnés avant tout bénévole chaque
mois il consacre une soirée pour initier
le public sur la savane le deuxième
dimanche de chaque mois
on est sur la savane on a un concept
avec la mairie de fort-de-france en
accord dit oui et on initie baylet aussi
lit dans ses bas ce qu'on appelle dans
ses balles des biguines mazurkas valses
et monsieur tout le monde est invité à
apprendre à s'initier à des gens patravi
le dimanche 14 octobre l'association
attend les amateurs prennent aux statues
de joseph ou rendez-vous 18h les pieds
nus s'il vous plaît
pourquoi